we haven't seen you in a while America
you haven't changed a bit
as anchorman to the long-awaited sequel
to 2004 s The Legend of Ron Burgundy
hits theaters it's worth pointing out
Will Ferrell's fake newscaster is not
just wildly entertaining but hugely
instructive in our media soaked age here
are three reasons why anchorman 2 is
already the most important movie of the
year
face you when Ron Burgundy creates
ridiculous and over-the-top news
features it's impossible to ever take a
special report or breaking news
interruption uncritically ever again
face you well that's gonna do it for all
of us here at Channel 4 News by calling
attention to the actual production of
news and the often considerable
limitations of the people who make media
anchorman underscores that news is
invented not discovered and I'm Ron
Burgundy go yourself San Diego thanks
you for more than critically acclaimed
critiques such as network anchormen
brilliantly Lampoon's the
self-importance and deranged egos of
media stars for these reasons and more
and at a time when venerable media
outlets such as 60 minutes or firing
correspondents for inaccurate reports
and blatantly sucking up to power and
carbon - in its prequel should be
required viewing for everyone who takes
media literacy seriously for reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie